dans ces cieux troubler un point
lumineux mais ce n'est pas un point
d'espoir c'est un point lumineux et
mystérieux voilà que l'on reparle des
ovnis ovni66 volants non-identifiés
populairement les soucoupes volantes si
vous préférez un phénomène lumineux une
sorte de triangle dans le ciel de
provence une nuée blanche avec un point
rosa son centre pour les gens
d'angoulême une sorte d'embrasement
solaire en catalogne
enfin pour les spécialistes en réalité
il pourrait s'agir d'une sonde spatiale
qui aurait explosé avant de tomber ou
bien d'une capsule scientifiques lancés
du centre d'essais des landes et le
panache de gaz
éclairé par le soleil aurait dégagé la
combustion du troisième étage d'une
fusée ayant servi à l'expérience c'est
ce que l'on dit tout au moins à l'onera
qui responsable de l'expérience mais
vous imaginez bien que pour les
soucoupistes ce n'est pas du tout le cas
les soucoupistes attentif à toutes les
manifestations de ces phénomènes il
pourrait s'agir d'autre chose
les soucoupistes ils sont 500 en france
à peu près à observer le ciel a enquêté
à noter les moindres indices ils sont
500 comme ce monsieur lagarde que
christian paul de passe a rencontré dans
le massif central
monsieur lagarde observateurs enquêteurs
pour le centre d'étude baptisé centre
d'études lumière dans la nuit on les
forme des ovnis sont extrêmement
diverses
le type classique c'est la soucoupe
volante en forme d'assiette traverser le
cigare qui ava incliné à 20 degrés à
l'horizontale le ballon de rugby
la forme discoïdales la forme d'obus la
boule lumineuse
tous ces objets sont divers et nombreux
yatela ya également le satellite l'objet
satellites dont à vue à narbonne
avionneurs soudain qu'on a vu en
belgique qu'on a vu à megève
c'est un objet rond autour desquels
tournent des satellites plus ou moins
nombreux de 2 à 6
il ya également tous les jeux de lumière
dont sur sept dents sont susceptibles
ces engins
des voeux des multicolores de toutes les
couleurs mais les formes de ces engins
secondi fille devant les témoins même
dans les charentes
on a vu un objet qui a pris
successivement six formes différentes et
de vingt six témoins voici l'appareil
qui sert à détecter les objets volants
non identifiés
il est basé sur les variations du champ
magnétique terrestre
les u compose d'une barre aimante et qui
doit bien être orientée nord-sud d'une
pile qui met en contact le ronfleur
d'une perle mémoire qui soumet avec les
vibrations du ronfleur descend le long
de sa tige
lorsque nous allons simuler une
apparition d'objets volants non
identifiés en approchant un aimant
j'effectue des champs route et la perle
dessin landes à tige vous êtes bien sûr
libre de ne pas entendre le chant de la
perle et de ne pas croire aux soucoupes
volantes